yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing dumb fool Gansey oh okay that's
not why I played it before that's so
surprising remember the name hmm I don't
want it don't don't have any
recollection okay took on c6 that is an
early and early capture them it's not
completely uncommon for that to happen
but usually only after a six plate but
black and d5 is certainly the most
natural move looks a bit like a French
defense which is not good for me I have
my issues there but would seem yeah this
is how they the user usually play this
kind of this kind of line it's normally
again with the pawn a six here and don't
have it on a six so I can play a five in
one go okay well I kind of bad I can get
rid of the a pawn
now we close it down interesting okay
I'll go to the 7s no other choice really
I should be okay here right I mean
Bishop a6 is probably almost impossible
to prevent and if I can get rid of that
Bishop I should be okay maybe he's
playing rookie one Bishop a6 Bishop C
tune something like that
you
I think that's probably the way to do it
maybe I should have thought about that
but okay well except where else is the
business is the bishop supposed to go
really not clear if there is a different
square that makes any of any sense okay
so the Queen will probably jump out here
to g4 h five and the rook will come to
e3 that is probably the idea you try to
prevent that at least need to be six
maybe next it's going to probably place
a piece on the form if I play Queen to
b6 the sacrifice sacrifice on h7
I'm not entirely certain but it looks
like it
you're going to be six keep the pressure
on that ice cut through be three now
anyway oh that is not good you know what
this one
maybe I need counter play with rook a to
him and if he tamed if he trades rooks I
have Knight f8 as a potential defender
I'm scared anyway yeah that looks it
looks dangerous rhythm and again it has
this uncanny resemblance to fetch the
vets where I always get Shake mated yeah
that makes sense so let's do this
threatening rook b2 and if he moves the
bishop I can take on c2 as on f2 I have
got attack together Bishop is on on that
so this is actually not so easy to
answer
I'm not sure what his move is now I
think he probably overlooked something
there
yeah really he doesn't have a really
good move now
Bishop c1 maybe no then d4 drops d4
drops he he has this threat on aged six
so maybe the move he is going to play no
okay so here what am i doing now I take
on d4 this Bishop takes Queen takes
before yeah
Queen takes before I what is he doing
then he cannot be too as ataxia and rook
a bishop a1 I have Luke of course Luke
takes a one okay rook takes before
that's made on a one
okay Bishop takes d4 threatens the rook
and are threatening Bishop takes f2 he
has Queen h4 probably man so I take with
the Queen yeah check this and he has no
look at 7 which is important
some put it here you know very nicely
coordinated him I have no idea I didn't
like the position but all of a sudden I
had this count to play
maybe I'm just overly concerned
yeah with with the structures because I
have got checkmated so often in the
French that I tend to dislike those
positions here the engine does not
really know it doesn't give white
anything anyway yeah okay so if I've I
go back Ruki one made perfect sense to
me to get this retreat possibility to
see to so that it feels fine a3 mm-hmm
no that didn't occur to me at all no I
mean really
so can we get going is to go here and
now c8 or Queen a5
I'm still scared him maybe not justified
Quincy 7ko Queen a5 no then Bishop
yourself on there this is the thing and
all kinds of things happening what about
this no it cannot sacrifice I have this
phone yo that is super important
yeah this it's close
okay so loop c3 then over the engine
that's interesting here the engine wants
to sacrifice the Queen
that's very believable that this could
work
ie five is hanging the bishop can be
very strong you double here there that
that might work seems very very
believable that just works
Brooke c1 than g6 I have to be really
cold blooded here okay I took on b3 and
played the bishop out to make rookie
three more difficult and I think it's
rather logical yeah here I was scared
about the sacrifice and played age six
age six is not a move you're happy to
make but I thought he might be able to
sacrifice the engine does not agree at
first maybe maybe I'm wrong there I felt
ok kicking g8 is just not and maybe it
does work actually
I completely forgot that he's got this
possibility
so something something like this ookay
eight I can and then it's super tough
here this move
oh man
yeah well you cannot calculate those
things in in blitz it's just not
possible
king g6 is going to deuce and this one
the engine and sometimes in the indoor
sacrifice on h7 you need a little bit of
depth because there's the tech sometimes
is more yeah creeping nature it's not
like made but there are pieces
approaching and you cannot defend it and
now it gets too close to zero here so it
seems to be enough at least him so the
winner is probably this line with King J
but no no way of doing that in a blitz
game so I went age six and this is a big
blunder why ah nice this is a nice one
hmm okay okay yeah that makes my choice
really limited yeah that was lucky age
so it didn't see it means you form b7
yeah I seem to be okay there I am you
look at the evil maybe I'm really not
under that much pressure them and you
will be one less probably just bad right
yeah okay - and I'm winning here to win
not surprised by that I didn't I didn't
see a motor in it take take yeah Bishop
takes I was a bit afraid of this one I
mean I can just move the Queen as the
engine suggests but I think it's
probably just easier to do this where
you have a queen trade and most likely
but here everything is nicely
coordinated there is no a7 or anything
so just just a fool just a clean win
with all the other material and it was
still lucky if he had this tactic on a
six thanks for watching